15 seconds to drop what's our plan
great
i have all of that on camera get out of
my face let me be clear
our country is vulnerable
we need new heroes let's get to work
you went the wrong way
we're not a team nope
or partners
co-workers
we look damn good though
marvel studios the falcon and the winter
soldier original series streaming friday
only on disney plus
well i don't trust red wings hold on a
minute you don't have to trust red wig
but i'm gonna go see if he's right cause
i have a feeling they might be a part of
the big three
what big three the big three white pick
three
androids aliens and wizards that's not a
thing that that's definitely
no it's not every time we fight we fight
one of the three so who are you fighting
now gandalf yep
how do you know about gandalf i read the
hobbit in 1937
when it first came out so you see my
point no i don't
there are no wizards dr strange is a
sorcerer
a sorcerer is a wizard without a hat
think about it right i'm right i just i
just came up with that it's crazy
but look that's not the point these guys
aren't magical all right they use brute
force just like you
the incredibly annoying guy in front of
me with the staring problem i'm coming
with you no you're not
one minute two drop offset
so what's our plan
great so no plan
30 seconds enjoy your ride buck no you
can't call me that
why not that's what steve called you
steve knew me longer and steve had a
plan
15 seconds to drop i have a plan
really what is it
you